ingo hüttner weiter dr heinz pöhler er
ist leiter des gesundheitsamtes
göppingen und hier neben mir frau doktor
ist sollte piotrowski sie es hier im
haus die infektionsschutz expertin
ministerium und es ist so vorgesehen es
gibt kurze eingang statements drei stück
und danach können sie dann natürlich
ihre fragen stellen
ich bitte sie dass sie sich dann weil
wir jetzt nicht alle kennen kurz
vorstellen und auch das medium für das
sie tätig sind dann übergebe ich jetzt
das wort an minister lokal herzlichen
dank dass der fährte damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen kollegen hier auf dem
podium
herzlichen dank dass sie sich so
kurzfristig zeit genommen haben heute zu
der information für uns ist das sehr
wichtig weil wir benötigen sie als
multiplikatoren für ein weiterhin
besonnenes zielorientiertes auch kluges
umgehend dass die menschen seien sie
betroffen oder denken sie seien
betroffen auch von uns
handlungsanweisungen haben wir sie
besonnen und überlegt vorgehen können
darum ist es uns auch wichtig ganz
transparent wie wir es vom ersten tag an
bei den ersten verdachtsfällen anja auch
tatsächlich gehandelt haben ich hab
schon fehler gemacht also erste handeln
husten immer in die beute und janne den
tanz und sie wissen ja zehn sekunden
händewaschen nicht ins gesicht lange
also das sind so die kleinen feinheiten
die wir im übrigen auch immer wieder
informativ weitergeben auf unserer
homepage ist weil die sind genau die
dinge die sehr wichtig sind
sie wissen es bereits sie haben
dankenswerterweise berichtet dass eben
ein 25 jähriger mann aus dem kreis
göppingen sich vermutlich während eine
tolle reise mailand angesteckt hat also
dort angesteckt er hat nach der rückkehr
grippeähnliche symptome entwickelt einen
vorbildlichen weg von den ersten
symptomen tatsächlich zum abstrichen
behandlung das wird kaputt man ihn dann
auch noch
schildern seine partnerin hat
unspezifisches symptom ist es derzeit
auch in einer klinik da haben wir noch
keinen befund
generell hat sich für uns die
lagebewertung in baden württemberg und
nicht verändert ist es tatsächlich ein
einzelfall
die kontakte kunden ermittelt werden es
handelt sich insgesamt um 13 kontakte
die alle schon kontaktiert wurden
auch ein besuch im benachbarten und
neu-ulm im kino wurde jetzt auch von
herrn brockmann team mit dem bayerischen
kollegen kommuniziert ich selbst habe
heute morgen zwei mal schon mit jens
spahn telefoniert der ausreise aus
italien mit den gesundheitsministern der
eu und schweiz und anderen noch mal
klare vereinbarung gemacht hat lage
orientiert handeln keine
grenzschließungen besonnenheit
gesundheitskompetenz der menschen nunmal
fördern die wege von der symptom name
bis hin zum arzt zu schildern ihnen hier
die fachleute nun ganz bewusst klar
einzugehen
es gibt nach wie vor keinen kursierenden
virus bei uns er ist importiert er ist
ein einzelfall und ich denke sie sehen
unser bemühen ja schon vom ersten tag an
dass wir keine infektionsketten keine
lange infektionsketten entstehen lassen
wollen und sehr kurzfristig sehr schnell
agierend eingreifen
das haben wir vom ersten tag an gemacht
sie wissen wir waren das erste
bundesland ist dankenswerterweise am lga
nach berlin von der charité die testung
auf den profit 19 durchführen konnte das
kompetenzzentrum gesundheitsschutz
unterstützt
mit seiner fachlichen expertise alle
gesundheitsämter in vielfältiger weise
wir haben heute im anschluss an unser
gemeinsames gespräch hier
zusammentreffen mit der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung mit der ärztekammer mit der
baden-württembergischen
krankenhausgesellschaft mit den
kommunalen landesverbänden den
spitzenverbänden der kommunen die ja
auch für prävention
gesundheitsaufklärung betreuung ruhe
bewahren
verantwortlich sind also sie sehen wir
haben alle am geschehen beteiligten eng
angebunden
derzeit haben wir insgesamt 204 reise
rückkehrer aus risikogebieten vor allem
aus china im allgäu lga untersucht
auch wenn sie die fall definition des
robert koch instituts nicht immer voll
erfüllt haben haben wir sehr großzügig
das wort groß ist vielleicht falsch aber
sehr breit definiert untersucht und das
hatte ich denke ich auch in diesem fall
sehr gelohnt und das verhalten des 25
jährigen war wirklich vorbildlich das
wird ihnen herr brockmann und auch der
landrat verordnung mehr schilder
wir haben bereits zum 4 februar hat die
hotline für besorgte bürger eingerichtet
die sehr wichtig meine damen und herren
07 11 90 43 95 55 stuttgart davor war 90
43 95 55
und wie gesagt stehen wir im ständigen
austausch mit den bundesbehörden die
steuerung hat nach wie vor das
robert-koch-institut ich hatte heute
morgen zwei telefonate mit kollegen
sparen ein mit der kollegin hummel auch
wir werden auch die informationstexte
für reiserückkehrer die jetzt als ein
süddeutsches gebiet aus den südtiroler
laden auch dort ist der eine fall
ausschließlich ein import es ist keine
zelle die cd ist tatsächlich in lodi und
sonst nirgends also das ist für uns
sehr gut beherrschbar was heute auch
geschehen ist und es freut mich dass
sich herr ministerialdirigent schröder
begrüßen darf vom innenministerium heute
morgen wurde der interministerielle
verwaltungsstab eingerichtet mit allen
notwendigen beteiligten ministerien dass
wir auch im abgestimmten hand und die
frage wie es mit kindergärten und
anderen öffentlichen einrichtungen immer
gemeinsam mit glück haben herzlichen
dank herr schröder sitzt hier
es war jetzt nicht vorn aber wenn sie
konkrete fragen haben steht er gerne
auch zur verfügung und wir werden heute
nachmittag auch der bundesminister noch
mal zu einer telefonkonferenz einberufen
also sie sehen wir arbeiten sehr sehr
abgestimmt
tatsächlich was wirklich wichtig ist den
reiserückkehrern und aus den gebieten in
denen kobe 19 fällen vorkommen innerhalb
von 14 tagen nach ihrer rückkehr fieber
husten oder atemnot entwickeln sollen
erstens unnötige kontakte vermeiden nach
möglichkeit zu hause bleiben
beim husten niesen abstand zu anderen
menschen halten bzw
in die armbeuge niesen oder husten nach
möglichkeiten nur ein taschentuch
benutzen das sofort entsorgt wird
regelmäßig und gründlich zehn sekunden
mindestens hände mit wasser und seife
waschen und in der tat wir alle neigen
uns immer wieder ins gesicht zu langen
tatsächlich berührungen von nase augen
und mund vermeiden und nach
telefonischer anmeldung unter hinweise
auf die reiseregion den arzt aufsuchen
vorher anrufen nicht taktisch wohin
gehen dass wir einfach dann sehr schnell
die richtigen hilfen behandlungsangebote
anbieten können
ich bedanke mich nur mal hier bei allen
anwesenden auch beim landkreis göppingen
gesundheitsamt der klinik auch die
kollegen im gesundheitsamt sie werden
hören wie vorbildlich das abgelaufen ist
als der
junge mann mit symptomen dort auftauchte
so dass wir wirklich in unserem versuch
die lagen klein überschaubar
kontaktpersonen identifizierbar zu
halten damit keine ungesteuerten ketten
ausgelöst werden
dieser lagebeurteilung bleiben wir es
ist auch mit dem robert-koch-institut so
abgesprochen dass wir alle nach
jeweiliger einzel lage beurteilen welche
maßnahmen wir durchführen oder
verhaltensmuster wir empfehlen
herzlichen dank und ich darf gruppen
anbieten noch aus der sicht dieselbe
jahre weiterzuführen
herzlichen dank an minister
ja ich würde vielleicht einfach noch mal
kurz anfangen auszuführen wie denn das
geschehen abgelaufen ist damit noch mal
alle auf dem gleichen stand sind unsere
index fall zu nennen wir ja immer den
ersten patienten
der war auf einer italienreise vom 17
bis zum 21
februar zum montag bis freitag in
mailand mit seiner lebensgefährtin ist
dann zurückgereist am freitag hat am
samstag dann am sonntag tschuldigung am
sonntag gegen 13 uhr husten entwickelt
na also so was bin ich froh mal phasen
wird es ja und dann am nächsten morgen
nach dem aufstehen hatte er erhöhte
temperatur fieber das hat sich dann
sozusagen etwas ausgewachsen so gesagt
hat okay also ich bin krank und er hat
sich dann am dienstagmorgen mit dem
gesundheitsamt gemeldet
ja dort wurden nach kurzer rücksprache
veranlasst dass man den patient obwohl
er nicht aus diesen definierten kleinen
risikogebieten kommt aber doch eben aus
norditalien in gebieten in denen fälle
aufgetreten sind ein abstrich
untersuchung zu machen
köhler kann das nahfeld kurz ausführen
wie das konkret abgelaufen ist dann ist
an dem gleichen tag ist der abstrich ins
landesgesundheitsamt transportiert
worden wir haben es am gleichen tag
untersucht er ist positiv getestet
worden wir haben gestern abend denn vor
allem las dass der patient in die klinik
eingewiesen wird und dort ist er jetzt
bei einem anständigen allgemeinzustand
mit einer leichten erkrankung isoliert
und gut versorgt seine gefährtin die ihn
begleitet hat hat ebenfalls leichte oder
unspezifische symptome entwickelt ja
also das geht schon so in richtung
asymptomatische oder mail die sie wohnt
nicht im gleichen landkreis also nicht
in gippingen sondern in tübingen
wir haben gestern abend oder gestern
nacht noch veranlasst dass sie ebenfalls
stationär aufgenommen wird und sie hat
einen abstrich erhalten die
ergebnisse der untersuchungen liegen
noch nicht vor die kommen im laufe des
nachmittags die freundin die besucht
wurde
in italien ist hat ebenfalls am
samstag/sonntag unspezifische symptome
entwickelt die ist inzwischen eigentlich
schon wieder genesen
sie ist in italien häuslich abgesondert
hat auch einen test erhalten das
ergebnis liegt ebenfalls noch nicht vor
also diese drei personen sozusagen sind
entweder diagnostiziert oder als
verdachtsfall unter abklärung des
weiteren gibt es eben aus dem privaten
umfeld unseres erkrankten zwölf andere
also die 13 sind die lebensgefährten
oder freundin plus zwölf weitere
familienmitglieder oder freunde die
einen engen kontakt zu ihm hatten wir
konnten das gestern abend dank der
arbeit des gesundheitsamtes durchweg
abklären alle personen sind erreicht
worden
sie sind befinden sich alle in
häuslicher absonderungen also das ging
sehr sehr zügig und wir können die
ketten bisher sehr genau
nach erfolgen wir haben noch eine kleine
offene geschichte der patient war mit
einem seiner kontaktpersonen bei einem
kinobesuch in neu ulm auf der
bayerischen seite wir haben heute nacht
mit den bayerischen kollegen der
taskforce gesprochen
die bayerischen kollegen haben sich
heute morgen getroffen und lassen
ausrichten das ist heute nachmittag eine
kleine pressemitteilung des bayerischen
ministeriums oder der taskforce gibt und
gemeinsam mit dem zuständigen
gesundheitsamt das ist neu ulm wird dann
vor ort sozusagen niederschwellig mit
der bevölkerung noch mal geklärt oder
versucht zu klären wer denn dieses
diesen kinobesuch wahrgenommen hat so
dass dort in neu ulm und umgebung
diese sache noch mal geklärt wird
dort gibt es also eine anzahl von den
momentan nicht bekannt eine
kontaktperson die aber nicht eng sind
dort gibt es ja keinen face to face
kontakt es ist ein großer raum
aber wollte das nicht einfach
unberücksichtigt lassen und die
bayerischen kollegen adressieren das
jetzt das wären erstmal die information
die ich für sie hat vielleicht noch mal
zusammenfassen es gibt vier landkreise
die jetzt betroffen sind weil diese
kontaktperson unseres index falls eben
nicht alle aus dem landkreis göppingen
sind sondern wir haben
tübingen stuttgart und ulm die mit
betroffen sind die gesundheitsämter dort
sind in ebenfalls informiert und
eingebunden worden gestern abend wie
schon gesagt diese 13 personen die wir
genannt haben bezieht sich auf alle vier
kreise die sind also sozusagen alle
schon adressiert und versorgt das wäre
es erst mal von meiner ferien dann würde
ich weitergeben an hamburg
für den landkreis göppingen herzlich
begrüßen es ist gut dass so viele
medienvertreter da sind und dass über
sie eine umfassende information der
bevölkerung erfolgen kann denn wir
erleben dass im augenblick im landkreis
göppingen und sicherlich auch darüber
hinaus ist eine große verunsicherung der
bevölkerung da und ein großer bedarf an
informationen und die möchte man heute
umfassend geben
es wurde schon berichtet seit gestern
abend wissen wir dass wir einen positiv
getesteten fall haben das ist dem
patienten vergleichsweise gut geht es
klinisch stabil und wichtig ist er ist
isoliert wir fühlen uns auch gut
vorbereitet auf die ece situation warum
fühlen wir uns gut vorbereitet weil wir
in den letzten wochen schon einige
verdachtsfälle hatten im januar im
februar
diese verdachtsfälle wurden alle negativ
getestet aber sie haben uns erfahrungen
mit auf den weg gegeben erfahrungen in
einer sehr guten zusammenarbeit die wir
zwischen gesundheitsamt und kliniken mit
allen vertretern vor allem auch mit den
landesbehörden haben
es ist eine prima zusammenarbeit wir
fühlen uns da sehr gut aufgestellt wir
haben die zeit auch der letzten wochen
genutzt um mitarbeiter zu schulen
netzwerke zu pflegen auch mit den
hausärzten um prozesse prozessabläufe
vor zu denken und die organisation zu
überprüfen
insoweit denken wir dass wir für diese
situation ist gut präpariert sind was
für uns wichtig ist ist als es sich
tatsächlich um einen sogenannten
patienten 0 handelt dass wir wissen
woher der infekt kommt und dass wir mit
der klaren ansprache dieser 13
kontaktpersonen gut die hälfte im
landkreis göppingen die anderen in
anderen landkreisen aber alle sind klar
angesprochen für alle ist auch verfügt
dass sie zu hause bleiben da sie damit
auch keine ansteckungsgefahr weitergeben
können wir glauben dass wir mit diesen
beiden maßnahmen den patienten zu
isolieren die kontaktpersonen zu
isolieren dass wir auch damit die
geeigneten maßnahmen ergriffen haben um
eine weiterverbreitung des virus zu
verhindern
ich sage das ganz bewusst weil parallel
auch in nordrhein-westfalen der fall
anders beurteilt wird aber auch ein dass
liegt dort sind wohl weitergehende
maßnahmen
verfügt worden wir sind alle miteinander
überzeugt davon dass diese maßnahmen für
unseren fall im landkreis göppingen die
richtigen sind ich denke es ist wichtig
zielgerichtet verantwortlich zu
reagieren aber auch mit dem richtigen
maß und auch besonnen und wir setzen
darauf dass wir mit diesen maßnahmen die
den virus in den griff bekommen und eine
weiterverbreitung verhindern können es
gibt mehrere intensität stufen eines
ausbruchsgeschehens 3 so sagen es die
fachleute und wir glauben dass wir da an
der unteren grenze sind weil wir genau
wissen wer ist der patient woher kommt
der infekt mit welchen maßnahmen können
wir hier entgegenwirken ich möchte in
richtung der bevölkerung einfach darauf
hinweisen dass wir im landkreis
göppingen gemeinsam mit dem land alles
tun um den schutz der bevölkerung
sicherzustellen und ich möchte einfach
auch appellieren da die ruhe zu bewahren
besonnen zu reagieren das ist für die
bevölkerung wichtig informiert zu werden
damit jeder weiß was er selber auch tun
kann
da sind die hygienemaßnahmen
angesprochen selbstverständlich werden
wir auch lage spezifisch die situation
immer wieder neu bewerten im augenblick
glaube ich dass wir genau die richtigen
maßnahmen veranlasst haben
das kann sich natürlich in zukunft auch
ändern falls die zahl der
kontaktpersonen unüberschaubar wird wir
haben einen krisenstab im landkreis
etabliert der ständig zusammen kommt mit
allen verantwortlichen fachbereichen und
wir werden da die lage ständig neu
bewerten und denken aber dass wir im
augenblick mit diesen maßnahmen gut
zurechtkommen vielen dank so ich gehe
davon aus dass es fragen gibt dann bitte
schön
nico esch dpa
sie haben die zwei kontaktpersonen
angesprochen die bereits getestet sind
wo das ergebnis noch aussteht was es mit
den übrigen elf werden die getestet wann
werden die getestet und man es damit im
ergebnis zu rechnen
dankeschön also es gibt inzwischen
übereinkunft robert-koch-institut dass
wir kompakt personen die nicht
symptomatisch sind nicht testen außer es
gibt spezifische indikationen noch mal
so wie ganz spezifischen hinweise die
einen dann im einzelfall davon abweichen
lassen aber ein generelles testen wird
von solchen kontaktperson wird
eigentlich nicht mehr empfohlen und auch
nicht durchgeführt daniel hubmann wird
fernsehen mich würde interessieren warum
sollte sich ja so ein bisschen anders
sieht die maßnahme in nrw vielleicht ein
bisschen übertrieben finden vielleicht
können sie das nochmal einordnen warum
diese maßnahmen jetzt nicht hier
für göppingen oder in baden württemberg
ergriffen werden da kann ich gerne was
dazu sagen maßnahmen
die maßnahmen bei infektionsgeschehen
werden ja immer an der situation
orientiert und bei uns ist es ganz klar
so wie es die vorredner beschrieben
haben ein einzelfall mit kontaktpersonen
nach den mir vorliegenden informationen
da bin ich nicht ganz auf dem stand
scheint es ja in nordrhein westfalen so
zu sein dass es zumindest zunächst keine
klare infektionsquelle gab in solchen
fällen kann sich natürlich eine
schulschließung oder sowas anbieten wenn
ich einfach ein anderes szenario habe
fälle die auftreten ohne dass man die
infektionskette oder ein verdacht hat wo
der ursprung der quelle ist und um da
eine mögliche weiterverbreitung ganz
früh zu unterbinden können solche
maßnahmen sinnvoll sein
er soll so die faz ich habe meine frage
sozusagen falls sich diese epidemie
weiter ausbreiten sollte in baden
württemberg können sie vielleicht mal
sagen welche kapazitäten hat zum
beispiel ihr landkreis an beatmeten
betten und wie ist diese zahl sozusagen
im falle einer ausbreitung dieses virus
hochzufahren fähigste auch landesweite
zahlen und welche szenarien greifen dann
für den landkreis göppingen kann ich
sagen dass im moment die intensivstation
an den alb fils kliniken sehr gut
ausgelastet ist wir haben im
routinebetrieb im moment annähernd alle
betten auf der intensivstation belegt
würden aber natürlich wenn es notwendig
wird wenn wir uns dann in eine größere
anzahl von beratungspflichten patienten
mit corona viruserkrankungen bewegen den
routinebetrieb in der klinik zurück
fahren sind das war dort beatmungsgeräte
frei bekommen das ist im moment nicht
notwendig wir haben im moment einen
leicht erkrankten patienten der absolut
stabil auf die isolation station
gepflegt und betreut werden kann und von
daher halten wir den klinischen routine
betrieb im moment aufrecht und loten
dann den bedarf jeden tag neu aus als
nächstes auf der liste habe ich die frau
bäuerlein
ihre gebäude seien südkorea ich
vielleicht an haben luca wir haben ja im
moment faschingsferien noch in baden
württemberg viele menschen nie aus dem
süden ziehen in der schweiz in
norditalien vielleicht auch in den
bergen bekommen das ist nicht so richtig
mit kommen in kontakt mit vielen anderen
menschen verschicken war auch eine
veranstaltung mit vielen anderen
menschen in kontakt war
gehen sie davon aus dass sich jetzt mit
den rückkehrern aus den faschingsferien
noch die zahl der möglicherweise
erkrankten noch deutlich erhöht und
sollten denn die rückkehrer die jetzt
kommen irgendwelche vorsichtsmaßnahmen
ergreifen
also wir haben es gibt vom robert koch
institut heute ganz neue haus für
rückkehrer aus italien empfehlungs blatt
wir haben in absprache auch mit der
bayerischen kollegin der ministerin
melanie huml abgesprochen dass wir noch
einmal speziell weil wir süddeutschen
länder ja auch stärkere gruppen haben
die dort urlaub gemacht haben in die
winterferien sind noch sind wie gesagt
ein importierter fall in teheran ist es
keine eigene quelle auch im umfeld nicht
dass wir aber genau diese hinweise diese
verhaltenshinweise die wir ihnen gerade
geschildert haben versuchen an diese
hinzubekommen
es ist tatsächlich so es werden
informationsbroschüren auch gemeinsam
oder blätter ausgeteilt in den zügen in
den fernbussen sie spielen dabei eine
wichtige rolle auch die radios spielen
dabei eine wichtige rolle darf auch
mache jetzt keine werbung aber ich fand
heute swr leute sehr hilfreich mit dem
virologen und biochemiker stürmer heute
dieses ganz besonnen und kluge zwei
stunden gespräch zu machen wo die leute
sehr klar informiert werden wie die
schritte sind
wenn ja auch gerade vorgestellt haben
und darum gehen wir weil wir bisher
immer von einzel situationen ausgehend
tatsächlich auch weiterhin wenn es je zu
welchen kommt immer von isolierten
situationen die wir dann in der lage
beurteilen und deren kontakthäufigkeit
wird dann identifizieren aus so dass wir
nicht von großen summen derzeit ausgehen
sie hat eine rückfrage trat bayern nur
nachfrage weil die frage von kollegen
sollten noch nicht beantwortet wurde
nach den kapazitäten
generell gilt wir haben sehr gut
ausgestattete krankenhäuser die vor zwei
jahren die influenza herausforderung
hatte in diesen kliniken auch dazu
geführt dass die kapazitäten auch die
mit intensiv beten mit externer beatmung
tatsächlich dann auch ausgenutzt wurden
die klinik management sind in diesem
fall darauf eingerichtet so dass unsere
kliniken haben wir heute mittag auch
gleich das gespräch mit der
baden-württembergischen
krankenhausgesellschaft genau diese
punkte auch erörtern auch kapazitäten
steuerung wir haben insgesamt in baden
württemberg 3000 intensivbetten derzeit
haben wir einen positiven fall lassen
sie noch einen 2 3 4 dazu kommen
im rahmen dieser 3000 intensiv beten wir
haben hier in stuttgart mit dem robert
bosch und dem katharinen sehr starke
maximalversorger also wir sind ja
landauf landab mit unseren kliniken sehr
sehr gut gefallen mir auch in den
letzten jahren stark in sie investiert
möchten sie noch was ergänzen ja
vielleicht darf ich an der stelle
ergänzen dass es für uns im
klinikmanagement tatsächlich routine ist
uns innerhalb der unterhalb den kliniken
abzustimmen
darüber welche kapazitäten tatsächlich
verfügbar sind
wir haben mittlerweile ein system
eingerichtet wo wir
die kapazitäten von anderen kliniken
teilweise auch online sehen also wenn
intensivstationen beispielsweise in der
aufnahme kapazität reduziert sind
dann können wir dort im kollegialen
austausch tatsächlich auch sehr sehr gut
abstimmen wo gegebenenfalls einen
patienten versorgt werden könnten das
ist für uns routine geschäft wir haben
heute morgen beispielsweise auch mit dem
robert bosch krankenhaus schon kontakt
aufgenommen
wenn sich der patient verschlechtern
sollte vom klinischen bild ja so dass
dort schon mal informationen vorliegen
und eine enge kooperation und abstimmung
zwischen den kliniken reibungslos
funktionieren kann
jetzt habe ich mehrere wortmeldungen
gibt's jetzt speziell dazu zur
versorgung betten versorgung fragen dann
würde ich nämlich jetzt ein franke
zweite geben
ich würde gleich sind noch fragen dort
behütet wie ist die karte also wie ist
die belegen belegungssituation im moment
in baden württemberg also sind überhaupt
intensivbetten frei im größeren
kapazitäten also ich kann jetzt
natürlich nicht für die intensiv
kapazitäten in baden württemberg
sprechen
in unserem umfeld sind die intensiv
kapazitäten im moment relativ
ausgelastet wobei man dort natürlich
immer up schicht muss welche patienten
liegen auf intensivstationen und da ist
es auf jeden fall möglich auch patienten
beispielsweise haben wir planungen für
morgen patienten die heute operiert
werden die sind für morgen auf einen
intensiv wird gebucht solche war lenzen
lassen sich dann bei bedarf und wenn es
wirklich notwendig ist tatsächlich auch
schaffen
aktuelles irgend davon auszugehen dass
die intensive kapazitäten eher gut
ausgelastet sind und gut genutzt sind
wir hatten beispielsweise in den letzten
vier wochen etwa führt etwa 90 influenza
nachweise also wir laufen im moment ja
auch in einer krippe routine krippe
situation wo wir teilweise auch
schwerere verläufe von patienten sehen
und dann an sie herr minister lura die
frage in welcher phase befinden wir uns
denn jetzt gerade in baden württemberg
sie kommen aus dem urlaub zurück das
klingt ja schon zunächst mal irgendwie
dramatisch ist es jetzt schon so eine in
anführungszeichen katastrophen modus
oder noch große gelassenheit
ich war ja nicht so weit weg nein auch
bereit morgen durch der frische schnee
gestapft mit der rhätischen bahn vor
bergen noch gefahren und dann hierher
selbstverständlich liebe leute also ich
weiß ja die ganze zeit man überlegt ja
geht man überhaupt dann wie gesagt wir
können das telefon ist wir waren immer
in verbindung
aber wenn wir so eine situation haben
dann ist man hier das ist doch keine
frage das ist deswegen hat man sogar
katastrophen modus keine frage wir
stimmen uns ab für mich ist es auch
wichtig die ganzen koordinativen sachen
auch zu merken auch mit dem kollegen
bundesminister wo klar war dass nach dem
12 notrufe aus rom dass wir das
gemeinsam abstimmen das ist das ist
durch die schönheit dieses jobs dass man
mit so viel tolle leute wichtige
aufgaben managen kann also um wir
schätzen ist tatsächlich so ein dass wir
ruhig besonnen lage orientiert es im
blick haben und kein grund zur unruhe
ist es gibt kein grund zur großen
besorgnis wir sind kapazität
organisatorisch kommunikativ wirklich
gut aufeinander abgestimmt sollte je
eine andere lage eintreten die man aber
halt don't make the world from auf
tomorrow sondern das gas sehen was kommt
und das war mir und das haben wir sehr
frühzeitig gemacht bereits anfang
februar haben wir uns ganz systematisch
mit allen partnern mit den lokalen
gesundheitsämtern mit den klinik mit der
ärzteschaft abgestimmt und vor allem lga
und es war tatsächlich wie es auch der
landrat sagte dadurch dass wir sehr
frühzeitig auch die verdachtsfall
verdachtsfall fragen so feinsinnig und
so intensiv gepflegte routine bekommen
wie der etwaige ablauf zu sein hat und
das macht sie jetzt für uns auch durch
die das labor dieses mal bei euch haben
das ist einfach eine sensation dass wir
das so schnell sein kunden merken wir
dass wir da einfach sehr geschult
miteinander umgehen
ich möchte es vielleicht noch ergänzen
dass wir sind nach wie vor in der
content phase wo sie sehen wo wir jedem
einzelnen verdachtsfall nachgehen und
sollte dann sich etwas ergeben so wie
wir es jetzt haben sind wir immer noch
in der lage zu reagieren und das ist
wirklich sauber abzuarbeiten nicht mehr
minister hat gesagt man weiß nicht was
morgen kommt oder übermorgen ab nächste
woche aber noch sind wir in diesem modus
und in dieser phase der epidemie in dem
wir das wirklich im einzel management
auch wenn es manchmal eigentlich
dringend aufwändig ist auch wenn wir
einen letzten freitag denken mit den
kirchheimern den die zurückgekommen sind
ja das haben wir mit dem esslinger
gesundheitsamt gemeinde das ist
natürlich anstrengend es ist klar wenn
sowas schnell kommt aber wir sind in der
lage das so zu machen und wir sind in
der phase
und deswegen ist es an dieser stelle
nicht eine entwarnung natürlich denn die
situation ist ja ernst zu nehmen ganz
klar sonst gäbe es keine
pressekonferenzen und sonst würden wir
nicht hier sitzen
aber die sache ist sozusagen erstmal gut
abgedeckt und anständig adressiert ich
hatte als nächstes frau teams auf der
liste der infrage zu zwei
verdachtsfällen im kreis konstanz die es
wohl geben soll ob ihnen da mehr bekannt
ist dazu und was da drin ist ist mir
nichts näheres bekannt es werden also
nicht verdachtsfälle im engeren sinn
sein die aus einem der definierten
risikogebiete kommen zu den personen die
vermutlich in norditalien und ehrlich
unterwegs waren und symptome haben die
gibt es aber natürlich zuhauf also ich
kenne sie jetzt noch nicht wobei die
telefone natürlich heiß laufen und wir
hatten jetzt heute vormittag nicht so
viel zeit dass wir sozusagen in der lage
besprechen noch mal jeden jede einzelne
meldung die reinkommen ist durchgegangen
sind aber wir haben keine hinweisen
keine erkenntnis auf bevorstehende
weitere bestätigte fälle
als nächstes hat sich der herr da bei
den kameras gemeldet
hagen stegmüller von der bild ich wollte
mal fragen nehmen wir jetzt kommt einer
der königstraße und apotheke und hustet
und erzählt vielleicht der apothekerin
noch ich war gerade in china oder
norditalien und die apothekerin schöpft
verdacht wie geht es dann konkret weiter
er fühlt sich berufen
naja den kfz festen wohnsitz oder auch
nicht und dann geht er wieder
also ich weiß also ich meine es gibt
keine denunziationen es gibt keine
aktive falls suche im sinne von
einsammelt menschen auf die irgendwo
waren oder nicht in die symptome haben
oder nicht es gibt hinweise für die
bevölkerung dass diejenigen die in den
gebieten waren es eigenverantwortlich
handeln wie unser patient sich also
melden kontakt aufnehmen zum
medizinischen system und dann wird das
abgearbeitet und wenn wir dann einen
bestätigten fall haben gehen wir dem so
wie wir es gerade geschildert haben nach
und lösen das dann auf als nächstes die
gabe hier fahren bitte sarina sprengel
mediengruppe rtl ich habe noch eine
frage zum patienten selbst wir haben
schon gesagt es geht ihm den umständen
entsprechend gut glücklicherweise
trotzdem kann einen diese diagnose ja
durchaus angst machen deshalb meine
frage wie hat er das aufgefasst dass er
tatsächlich an corona virus erkrankt ist
und wie kommt er in dieser isolations
situation aktuell klar
vielleicht zuerst vom gesundheitsamt wir
hatten den erstkontakt er wurde schon
vorher aufgeklärt dass ein gewisses
risiko besteht dass sonst hätten wir
keinen abstrich genommen wir haben dann
zu ihm auch gleich gesagt dass er zu
hause bleiben soll und damit rechnen
muss dass der positiv ist also keine
weitere kontakte haben soll zu seiner
familie als wir gestern abend angerufen
haben hat er als ganz gefasst
aufgenommen hatte schon denke ich schon
ein bisschen damit gerechnet wir haben
dann mit ihm gesprochen und er konnte
uns alle kontaktpersonen die er die
letzten tage hatte ausschreiben mit
e-mail-adressen und so weiter so dass
wir das praktisch aus sehr gut
abarbeiten konnten und die angehörigen
informieren konnten und auch den hinweis
dass jetzt in die klinik kommt und dort
14 tage isoliert werden muss
ich denke mit dem hp schon vorher
auseinandergesetzt wie sich jetzt in der
klinik verhält ja das kann ich natürlich
jetzt nicht minutengenau ergänzen
heute morgen war allerdings da überhaupt
keine stör gefühl in anführungszeichen
unser personal ist auch im umgang mit
isoliert patienten absolut trainiert von
daher kann ich im moment sagen absolut
hohe absolute disziplin jetzt der hatten
sie noch eine rückfrage nachfrage die
kollegen der welt eine ganz kurze
nachfrage weil ein biologe sich das
jetzt parallel bei uns im programm auch
angeguckt hatte der so ein bisschen
verwundert war dass man die anderen
leute die er quasi sich vielleicht auch
infiziert haben dass man da kein test
machen dass man jetzt bei denen kein
test macht das ist ja jetzt würde ich
jetzt mal als laie sagen nicht so
aufwendig so einen test zu machen warum
wartet man erst dass der symptome
entstehen und führt nicht einfach einen
test durch hat man hat dann gewissheit
ganz einfach weil der test relativ wenig
bis gar keine aussagekraft hat also
erstmal muss der patient ja erst mal
krank sein damit er jemand anderes
anstecken kann dann muss er diese person
erst mal einstecken dann müssen diese
leute erstmal eingesteckt werden müssen
sie dann in kopieren und irgendwann gäbe
es dann wenn die menschen sich
tatsächlich infiziert haben einen
positiven test und da diese leute
häuslich isoliert sind haben wir
überhaupt gar keinen vorsprung
irgendwelche abstriche zu machen und die
uns eine falsche sicherheit geben ich
bin negativ ich habe kein problem warum
soll ich den in der häuslichen
isolierung bleiben das ist die frage die
dann kommt das heißt wir sehen darin
keine benefiz es gibt manchmal
entscheidungen bei denen man jetzt im
einzel verhältnis ja erwähnt anderes
macht aber vom grundsatz her hilft uns
das nicht weiter und löst die probleme
oder sozusagen oder vereinfacht den
umgang mit der ganzen situation nicht
und wir binden wir sozusagen benutzen
unsere ressourcen da wo wir sie wirklich
brauchen
na ja also wir haben jetzt keine
engpässe im labor bisher aber es macht
keinen sinn dinge zu machen von denen
ich wirklich überzeugt sind oder die wir
nicht wirklich für notwendig halten
jetzt die damen der vorletzten reihe
bitte stuttgarter nachrichten ich wollte
noch mal auf den anfang von corona in
deutschland zurückblicken das wagen
glaube ich die rückkehrer aus china zu
diesen bayerischen unternehmen diesen
aussieht autozulieferer webasto von
denen einige dann auch in quarantäne
gekommen sind da gab es fälle und auch
krankheitsfälle wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere können sie jetzt im rückblick
darauf sagen also
wie dort die lage ist also gibt es da
leute die an dem virus erkrankt waren
und in der zwischenzeit wieder gesund
geworden sind und können sie jetzt also
sozusagen der theoretische fall
jedenfalls näher gerückt ist nach baden
württemberg auch etwas dazu sagen wie
der krankheitsverlauf den haben sie ja
in den letzten monaten besser
kennengelernt seit des virus in china
aufgetaucht ist also wie läuft es wie
lange dauert es normalerweise wenn
jemand die krankheit kriegt wie
schwerwiegend ist das wie fühlt er sich
also und wie lange dauert es bis er
wieder gesund werden kann
die bayerischen patientinnen und
patienten sind bis auf einen alle aus
dem krankenhaus entlassen und gelten als
genesen
das waren so genannte eher leichtere
verläufe wobei man schon auch sagen muss
bei den über 50 jährigen waren die
verläufe etwas härter als bei den
jüngeren also das ist auch schon auch
der allgemeine hinweis risiko
disposition wenn man älter ist ist man
auch etwas auch anfälliger kinder
stecken das in der regel gar nicht so
schlecht weg das heißt auch die
ärzteschaft auch des behandelten
schwabinger klinikums vernetzt sich auch
mit der ärzteschaft in den ländern
hinaus es gibt einen austausch auch über
die behandlungsformen wie antiviral bis
symptomatisch gearbeitet wurde sodass
das state of the art auch dann
tatsächlich transportiert wird wie
gesagt diese verläufe gelten als dafür
sorgen eher leichtere verläufe jetzt
haben wir heute ja den medien entnommen
dass infizierte mann aus
nordrhein-westfalen in einer sehr
bedrohlichen lage sich befindet also das
ist offensichtlich auch mit länger schon
mit symptomen auch unbehandelt und
unentdeckt auch umgang hatte das ist
vielleicht der unterschied bis
bayerische war alles auch sehr schnell
im prinzip noch zu selten vorgehens
formel wie wir es tun der im roten
pullover klaas vom zdf mit zwei fragen
eine an den herrn brockmann zu den tests
noch mal ist das virus tatsächlich isst
dann nachweisbar wenn ein patient schon
symptome hat oder theoretisch auch der
forschung und eine frage an den
herrnhütte sie sagte schon der patient
sehr leicht erkrankt sei isoliert was
macht man da genau mit ihm in dieser
isolation zu situation
vielen dank also die erste frage die sie
an mich gestellt haben es ist nach wie
vor nicht ganz klar man weiß dass es
wenige man weiß von wenigen patienten
ich muss das richtige sagen nein von
wenigen personen dass sie als
symptomatisch waren also weltweit denn
china hat niemand zeit da abstriche von
irgendwelchen leuten zu machen die keine
probleme haben wir kennen das von dem
einen oder anderen fall also es gibt
schon im einzelfall menschen die ganz
asymptomatisch sind aber trotzdem einen
virus nachweis haben
das ist so ein teil thailand wird der
zweite teil der antwort wäre es gibt bei
vielen viralen erkrankungen sind
sogenannte proto mal phase die einen tag
geht vielleicht auch zwei und da kommt
es schon auch vor dass diese personen
dann schon einen positiven test haben
dass das vollbild der krankheit nicht da
ist deswegen agieren wir auch bei den
kontaktpersonen management schon noch
mal mit so ein bisschen in puffer und
sagen okay
er hatte kontakt am montag da war schon
krank mit dem und dem und am sonntag
waren noch nicht krank aber
möglicherweise in der brot roman phase
mit wem hatte er den tag engen kontakt
und die leute sind bei uns mit auf der
liste das heißt wir adressieren das mit
da ist also schon sohn so ein puffer
drin also ja es kann sein dass die
vielleicht vorher schon positiv sind
aber es ist auch immer eine frage wie
gut ist wie viele abstriche material hat
man erwischt wie viel viren sind da
eigentlich drin also die spezifität der
des ganzen hängen auch ein bisschen vom
genommenen material ab insofern darf man
ist es nicht so einfach zu beantworten
aber ja es ist schon auch in der frühen
phase der erkrankung oder vielleicht im
brutto mal stark wie möglich dass jemand
test positiv ist ja zu ihrer zweiten
frage unser patient wird aktuell
engmaschig überwacht das heißt
überwachen temperatur kreislauf
parameter entsprechende laborparameter
des blutes eine spezifische therapie
erhält er im moment nicht
er ist so leicht erkrankt dass es da
keine notwendigkeit gibt für spezifische
therapie sollte sich einen verlauf
verschlechtern dann könnte man natürlich
über spezifische antivirale therapie
nachdenken aber dann sind weil
insbesondere dann auch tatsächlich im
bereich der intensivtherapie und dann
geht es darum organe die gegebenenfalls
ausfallen lunge oder ähnliches zu
unterstützen so weit sind wir im moment
überhaupt nicht wir gehen davon aus dass
der patient ähnlich wie die bayerischen
patienten sehr moderaten und leichten
verlauf haben wird das ist auch der
grund warum unser normaler klinische
routine betrieb völlig unbeeinträchtigt
im moment läuft wir konnten den
patienten gestern aufnehmen ohne dass er
einen weiten weg durch die klinik
genommen hat das war exzellent
vorbereitet exzellent kommuniziert im
vorfeld so dass der patient unmittelbar
auf der isolierstation aufgenommen
werden konnte nicht über eine
notaufnahme oder ähnliches gehen musste
und von daher ist der absolute
routinebetrieb heute auch weiterhin
gewährleistet jetzt der kollege bitte
hinter dem welt kollegen ludger möllers
ich bin für die schwäbische zeitung
unterwegs
ich habe eine frage zu dem kinobesuch
wenn sich die leute doch melden sollen
dann müssten wir wissen welches kino
welcher film und wann dann können wir
das auch abfragen
ja also die der besuch des kinos hatte
auf der bayerischen seite stattgefunden
deswegen kümmern sich erst mal die
bayerischen behörden wurde heute mittag
die presse mitteilung geben ich kann
dazu sagen es war ein neukunde cineplex
der film hieß bis 20 uhr sozusagen also
das war ist also und zwar am
samstagabend klar
am samstag aber wie gesagt das neue uhr
im gesundheitsamt und die lgl also die
bayerische landes
das heute mittag adressieren und vor
allem mit der lokalen presse denn machen
wenn man sie sind jetzt natürlich lokal
oder regional aber das ist dann wirklich
ja also fern werden sie da auch noch mal
vielleicht ein informiert oder gehört
wenn ich jetzt keine fragen zu den bad
boys mehr gibt dann würde ich frau
bäuerlein als nächste aufrufen
ich habe vielleicht mal eine
vergleichende frage ist doch wo hört man
hat vorher schon gesagt wir haben ja im
moment auch influenza hoch zeit und es
wird ständig gesagt dass an der
influenza an der krippe jährlich in
deutschland weit mehr menschen sterben
als zum beispiel jetzt auch in china
schon an dem virus gestorben sind
kann man denn wenn du bist so sagen darf
die epidemische kraft dieses virus
irgendwie in verbindung setzen im
vergleich setzen zur grippe dass man mal
einschätzen kann wie gefährlich ist denn
die situation tatsächlich denn
einerseits sagt nur den bürgern es
besteht kein grund zur besorgnis
an der influenza erkranken deutlich mehr
menschen und andererseits erleben wir ja
hier das sozusagen der stark das
gesundheitswesen das ganz große besteck
auf waren wie passt das zusammen
also vielleicht bevor jetzt ist formal
noch noch fachkundiger und
auch fachterminologie erklären
zwar sagen warum war das große besteck
auf weil man natürlich keinen neuen
zusätzlichen erreger in der
größenordnung einer influenza haben
wollen
also das ist doch ganz klar dass wir
alles daran tun dass es dort keine
eigene quellen gibt
und tatsächlich ist so als wir ganz am
anfang ich kann mich noch gut erinnern
bei der ersten besprechung mit dem
robert-koch-institut um
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen hab mir
er machte erst das corona ist eine ganz
so aggressiv wie wie die uns bekannten
influenza vielen stimmen
ich glaube dass wir heute ganz
bescheiden sagen müssen vermutlich ist
derzeit der korona eine idee aggressiver
wie die influenza die wir derzeit in
diesem influenza dabei und haben das
influenza 17
das so ganz massiver da waren die
influenza stämme ist sicher wesentlich
aggressiver wie jetzt corona und
influenza so ist es tatsächlich so werde
ich mich auch selbst hüten jemals noch
einen vergleich anzustellen was wir
aggressiver oder nicht wir müssen beides
gleicher weise ernst nehmen auch der
bevölkerung nach wie vor sagen
auch bei der influenza alles mögliche
tun vom impfen über hygiene auch immer
achtsam zu sein vor allem wohl marable
gruppen ältere frau erkrankte und die
ganze risikogruppen insofern ist es mit
dem großem besteck ganz richtige würde
ich sagen akut wie präventive maßnahme
dass wir nicht noch zusätzlich eine
herausforderung von der großen dimension
haben
es gibt einen wesentlichen unterschied
zwischen influenza und dem corona virus
gestehen die influenza kommt jedes jahr
man kann davon ausgehen dass ein teil
der bevölkerung immun ist und aus
unserer sicht ein zu kleiner teil durch
impfung geschützt des corona virus
trifft auf eine
völlig naive bevölkerung also es kann
wirklich jeden treffen weil keiner im
vorfeld abwehrmechanismen dagegen hat
wir haben gehört es gibt leichte fälle
es gibt aber auch schwere fälle
wir kennen erste informationen aus
auswertung aus china was das für unsere
bevölkerung bedeutet eine ältere
bevölkerung vielleicht auch eine
bevölkerung mit mehr vorerkrankung
können wir im moment nicht einschätzen
das sind die gründe warum wir dieses
corona virus was doch so leichte
erkrankungen macht und für gleichzeitig
wenig todesfälle so ernst nehmen und zu
den todesfällen muss man einfach noch
ergänzen die 20.000 grippetoten in einer
saison die ermitteln wir erst nach der
saison aus den vorzeitigen sterbefällen
also die tatsächlich gemeldeten
grippetoten bewegen sich in der regel
auch in der dimension von wenigen
hundert in einer saison nicht jeder
influenza patient wird kriegt ein
labortest nicht bei jedem sterbefall
influenza wird klar dass es sich um
influenza handelt das erkennt man erst
wenn man die sterbefälle
nach abschluss des jahres auswertet da
gibt es dann im winter immer so ein peak
im vergleich zu vorjahren und da kommen
die 20.000 tote her
wir kennen jetzt nur die sterblichkeit
an corona aus china auch dort muss man
wissen die untersuchen ja auch nur
schwere fälle diese sterblichkeit kann
sich noch ändern also ich wäre mit
diesen vergleichen auch unter dem aspekt
sehr sehr vorsichtig im moment so ich
habe jetzt momentan noch sechs
wortmeldungen auf meiner liste nehme ich
sie noch dazu
vielleicht werden ja manche fragen auch
beantwortet
da steckt man die nächste ich wollte
noch mal kurz fragen welche behörde
hätte denn die befugnis zum beispiel
einen kindergarten oder eine schule
dicht zu machen oder auch vielleicht
eine im ganzen ortsteil abzuriegeln
und wie würde das abgestimmt und wer
würde es dann letztlich durchsetzen
ja also die grundlage dafür ist das
infektionsschutzgesetz die fsg in
paragraph 16 ist es festgelegt
da steht drin dass es die zuständige
behörde gemacht die zuständige behörde
ist die ortspolizeibehörde wenn gefahr
im verzug es kann es das gesundheitsamt
anordnen die ortspolizeibehörde
bestätigt ist dann die
ortspolizeibehörde das ist das
ordnungsamt und die können dann eine
polizeiliche köhler kann aus der front
berichten also wir sind in göppingen in
einem kleinen stab mittlerweile in
kontakt mit verschiedenen einrichtungen
polizei feuerwehr katastrophenschutz und
so weiter mit dem oder mit in dem ein
derartiges szenario eventuell mal
durchgesprochen wird es wird im
endeffekt so wie gesagt die
ortspolizeibehörde das durchsetzen
auf anraten des gesundheitsamtes sie
würden uns natürlich als regionales
gesundheitsamt dann eng mit den
überregionalen behörden
landesgesundheitsamt und so weiter
abstimmen
aber wir sind und das möchte ich
wirklich habe ton göppingen noch lange
nicht soweit bin mit dem jetzigen fall
ist es uns und da bin ich jetzt als
amtsleiter schon überzeugt gelungen die
kontaktpersonen so einzugehen sind dass
wir jetzt momentan nicht daran denken
müssen praktisch kindergarten oder
sonstige schulen oder sowas zu schließen
weil ich überzeugt bin dass von diesem
fall momentan keine kontaktpersonen oder
während mehr in die öffentlichkeit raus
gehen
ich dachte dass vielleicht ein punkt
noch ergänzen dieser job ist alltag für
die gesundheitsämter und für uns
bei jedem fall kann ein kind nicht in
die schule oder darf nicht den
kindergarten das ist sozusagen im
kleinen der gleiche vorgang natürlich
schließt man da nicht die schule aber da
darf dann jemand nicht gehen usw
also das ist alltagsgeschäft für uns und
deshalb werden natürlich in dem fall
möglicherweise etwas größere dimension
aber der grundsatz ist eigentlich der
gleiche jetzt habe ich noch die frau
thoms dankeschön eine frage noch werden
es vorhin von denen intensivbetten wie
sieht es denn mit den hausärzten aus
sind die vorbereitet wenn jetzt leute
davor sag ich jetzt mal nicht panik aber
bewusst sein hinlaufen und sich überall
dort testen lassen wollen untersuchen
lassen wollen sind die genug gebrieft
und vorbereitet aus diesem grund nachdem
wir schon viele kleine lagen gemacht im
informationsschreiben uns haben wir im
anschluss an die sitzung mit vertretern
der kassenärztlichen vereinigungen mit
vertretern der ärztekammer ein gespräch
wie wir da nur das was wir jetzt an
informationskette weil jeder
infektionskette sitzen wie eine
informations und kooperationsplattform
ihren eben das angerufen werden sind wie
auch der der praxisalltag ruhig
organisiert werden konnte dass wir dort
auch keine aufregung entsteht ja ich
habe nochmal eine organisatorische frage
vielleicht an herrn brocken auch an die
minister also können sie nochmal sagen
solche fälle jetzt wer hat sozusagen
koordinieren den hut auf wie haben sie
diese organisationsstruktur jetzt auch
angesichts dieser neuen lage verändert
und welche maßnahmen haben sie denn
jetzt januar überhaupt getroffen um
besser vorbereitet zu sein wir können
das noch mal auf summieren kann ich was
zu sagen also wir haben unsere pläne
einfach wieder aus der schublade gezogen
denn auch das geschehen was wir jetzt
haben ist er nicht so völlig neu
es hat sehr viel ähnlichkeit mit der
schweinegrippe pandemie wir haben uns
damals gut vorbereitet und in einer
ersten näherung kann man einige
maßnahmen daraus aufgreifen der
pandemieplan wurde jetzt aktuell noch
mal aktualisiert wir haben im vorfeld
auch die entsprechenden informationen
alle akteure informiert und das
geschehen ist einfach bis dato routine
es ist so wurde schon gesagt wir sind in
der containment phase wir beobachten ja
aber mit den anderen bundesländern und
mit dem rk ii das geschehen auch
weltweit und die besorgnis steigt dass
sich das vielleicht demnächst auch
verändern kann und um darauf vorbereitet
zu sein wollen wir jetzt auch noch
einmal prüfen dass alle akteure die
außerhalb der verwaltung agieren auch
ihre vorbereitung noch mal aktualisieren
auch das ist ein punkt der gespräche von
heute also wir besteht kein grund zur
beunruhigung aber wir bereiten uns vor
und wir sind auch hier im engen
austausch auch im haus wir haben bereits
seit ja zwar auch schon ende januar eine
erste ein erster schuss mit dem
innenministerium und mit dem
wissenschaftsministerium einberufen
einfach um alle akteure die damit eine
rolle spielen auch frühzeitig ins boot
holen und sie merken schon an den
aussagen die informationsketten werden
zunehmend breiter aufgestellt einfach um
sich für diesen fall auch vorzubereiten
den wir hoffen noch zu vermeiden aber
wenn er denn da ist es gut wenn man
vorher noch mal zusammen gesprochen hat
und seine jeweiligen pläne aktualisiert
hat
das habe ich noch zwei fragen auf der
liste die dame ja vielleicht ganz kurz
noch mal also wir haben so oft der
operativen ebene natürlich auch
ergänzung also die behandlungs
kompetenzzentren sind in der wirklichen
telefon schalte um sich abzustimmen das
wissen die speerspitze jahr für jahr für
die expertise sowohl in behandlung als
eben auch im management der fälle wir
sind in dem wäldchen telco bieten ki und
stimmen dort die am robert-koch-institut
und stimmen dort eben ab wie denn
sozusagen die empfehlung des aks auch
umgesetzt und gelebt werden können
das aufschreiben ist das ja ein von dort
aus geht es denn die gesundheitsämter
sind im föderalen system wo das
natürlich immer noch in den landkreisen
und kommunen abgearbeitet wird aber wir
haben sozusagen schon jetzt eine schöne
struktur wo wir uns mit oben austauschen
und es auch weiter geben und da schon
sozusagen um harmonisierung und
austauschen auch rückmeldung was
funktioniert an der basis nicht und was
ist gut was muss man anpassen
stattfindet und das ist schon eine
struktur die wir jetzt über das normale
hinaus schon seit wochen aktiviert haben
und die im wesentlichen beitrag leistet
auch dass das ak i denn seine empfehlung
ein passender und sagt das ist zwar auf
dem papier richtig aber das wird nicht
verstanden draußen und so und diese
dinge also da haben wir uns schon jetzt
in den letzten wochen noch mal deutlich
neu aufgestellt jetzt aber die dame im
hellen mikro
ja wer hat das mikrofon nix auch geber
wähler ja lubina rat von hit radio
antenne 1 und zwar ist noch mal eine
frage zu reiserückkehrern wird da jetzt
auch gezielt vielleicht gerade an den
flughäfen auf mehr sicherheit geachtet
oder wie geht man in dem bereich genau
vor also eher mit einem minister es
vorher schon vorgestellt es gibt jetzt
wir hatten ja vor einigen wochen
veranlasst dass sowohl die flughäfen als
auch die bahnhöfe
das merkblatt für die rückkehrer aus
china den aushängen und jetzt gibt es
irgendwie empfehlung speziell ja nochmal
für italien so dass wir immer noch mal
unterscheiden wir es den reiserückkehrer
und gesund für die ist nochmal die klare
botschaft es gibt nichts besonderes zu
tun kein grund für eine beunruhigung und
eben die reiserückkehrer aus den
gebieten wie wir es vorher gesagt haben
wo es den fälle gibt also norditalien
lombardei piemont die sich dann bei
symptomen eben an ihren medizinischen
versorgung also den hausarzt wenden soll
mit dem kurz abklären kann ich komme wie
gehen wir vor dass man mich untersucht
dass es ein abstrich gibt eine häusliche
isolierung üblicherweise vorzugsweise
und dann bei einem positiven vor allem
momentan ja als empfehlung noch die
aufnahme stationäre aufnahme ins
krankenhaus bisher und auch das 40 dann
ja möglicherweise in zukunft verändern
jetzt noch genau
er ist die dame und dann noch sie von
der dpa und dann würde ich schließen ja
nochmal bärbel frauen stuttgarter
zeitung
wenn ich zusammenfassen was sie jetzt
alle vorgetragen haben dann ist glaube
ich die aktuelle lage so eine die ja
relativ positiv ist geschuldet einer
sehr guten vorbereitung aber auch eine
große portion glück weil der göppinger
quasi der perfekte patient ist und sehr
besonnen und überlegen
reagiert hat auf glück kann man schlecht
bauen also insofern möchte ich noch mal
sozusagen die frage nach den aussichten
stellen
sie gehen schon davon aus also dass es
in nächster zeit mehr fälle geben wird
für die die behörden allerdings auch gut
vorbereitet sind man in die glaskugel
gucken ist immer sache und kaffeesatz
lesen auch aber natürlich wie wir leben
in einer globalisierten mobilen sehr
mobilen wählt da wird den einen oder
anderen noch geben können
der kommt aber ich glaube dass wir schon
und das war ja auch noch eine frage von
herrn sollte was hat es eigentlich
gemacht wir haben seit wochen dieses
thema auf eine sehr vernünftige klare
und kluge art und weise immer wieder
auch im öffentlichen kommunikation
segment gehalten so dass jeder der schon
mal irgendwo mal was kehrt kurz aha ich
kann mich diese schritte bis in hot line
internet nachgucken wie gehe ich damit
um
nach wie vor ist unser ziel im
containment dass wir tatsächlich die
einzelnen personen und ihre kontakte
noch identifizieren können und dann
musterhaft vorgehen so wie wir es ihnen
jetzt doch glaube ich mehrfach
geschildert habe und für diese
vorgehensweise haben wir uns in den
letzten wochen auch training by doing
sind wir immer routinierter besser
breiter geworden mit guten
kooperationspartner sowohl das
robert-koch-institut wie die anderen
kolleginnen kollegen an den ämtern wie
auch interministerielle mit dem em mit
den rettungsdiensten das ist wirklich
eine ganz ganz gute kooperation ist weiß
jeder vom anderen wasser zu tun hat und
das ist etwas ganz entscheidendes und
wir versuchen immer wieder und wenn man
mal rückmeldung bekommen dass irgendwo
mal war es nicht so ok lauf dass sich
jemand nicht gut informiert fühlt dass
ein arzt sagt ich bin noch nicht so gut
informiert
wollen wir das sofort aufnehmen und dann
diese bringschuld der information dann
auch erfüllen
ich hätte noch eine frage anknüpfend an
die frage nach den reiserückkehrern was
ist denn mit leuten die reisen vor sich
haben was würden sie den raten wenn die
sich sorgen machen ob sie irgendwo noch
hinfahren können
gibt es irgendwo region wo sie sagen da
würde ich jetzt besser nicht hinfahren
oder da bleibt man besser zu hause
zitiere den virologen stürmer heute
morgen im swr der wirklich sehr
entspanntes also wenn sie es nicht
unbedingt nötig ist würde die region
wurde jetzt kommt auch